Dear fellow scholars.
This is two minute papers with Dr. Carriage on IFA here in 2017.
So more than 300 episodes ago,
we talked about an algorithm that took a 3d model of a complex object and
would give us an easy to follow step-by-step breakdown on how to draw it
automated drawing tutorials. If you will.
This was a hand-crafted algorithm that used the graph theory to break these 3d
objects into smaller, easier to manage pieces.
And since then learning algorithms have improved so much that we started looking
more and more to the opposite direction,
and that opposite direction would be giving a crude drawing to the machine and
getting a photo realistic image.
Now that sounds like science fiction until we realize that scientists
at Nvidia already had an amazing algorithm for this around one and a half years
ago in that work, the input was a labeling, which we can draw ourselves.
And the output is a hopefully photo realistic landscape image that adheres to
these labels. I love how first only the silhouette of the rock is drawn.
So we have this hollow thing on the right that is not very realistic.
And then it is now filled in with a Bucca tool. And there you go.
And next thing you know, you have an amazing looking landscape image.
It was capable of much, much more bat.
What it couldn't do is synthesize human faces this way and believe it or
not, this is what today's technique is able to do. Look in goals,
our crudes catch as a guide image and outcomes and nearly realistic human
face that matches it. Interestingly, before we draw the hair itself,
it gives us something as a starting point, but if we choose to,
we can also change the hair shape and the outputs will follow our drawing really
well, but it goes much further than this,
as it bows a few additional appealing features. For instance,
it not only refines the output as we change our drawing,
but since one crude input can be mapped to many, many possible people.
These output images can also be further, are directed with these sliders.
According to the included user study,
journeyman users mainly appreciated the variety they can achieve with this
algorithm. If you look here, you can get a taste of that.
While professionals were more excited about the controllability aspect of this
method. That's what showcase with the footage with the sliders.
Another really cool thing that it can do is called face copy paste,
where we don't even need to draw anything and just take a few aspects of human
faces that we would like to combine. And
there you go, absolutely amazing.
This work is not without failure cases. However you have probably noticed,
but the AI is not explicitly instructed to match the eye Connors where some
asymmetry may arise in the output. I am sure this will be improved.
Just one more paper, the line.
And I am really curious where digital artists will take these techniques in the
near future.
The objective is always to get out of the way and have the artists spend more
time bringing their artistic vision to life and spend less time on the
execution. This is exactly what these techniques can help with.
What a time to be alive.
What you see here is an instrumentation for a previous paper that we covered in
this series, which was made by weights and biases.
I think organizing these experiments really showcases the usability of their
system weights and biases provides tools to track your experiments in your deep
learning projects. Their system is designed to save you a ton of time and money,
and it is actively used in projects at prestigious labs,
such as open AI Toyota research GitHub and more.
And the best part is that if you have an open source academic or personal
project, you can use their tools for free. It really is as good as it gets,
make sure to visit them through
wmb.com/papers or click the link in the video description to start tracking your
experiments in five minutes,
our thanks to weights and biases for their longstanding support and for helping
us make better videos for you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous support. And I'll see you next time.